and told all of the hostage families you
will keep your mouths shut or we will
shut them for you you will not be used
as a weapon against
us what if I told you that you can earn
the reward of an umrah without even
stepping foot in Mecca umrah itself is a
type of jihad and the reality of jihad
if you assist someone financially it's
as if you've partaken in this amazing
act by sponsoring someone for umrah you
become a part of their spiritual journey
and earn an umrah yourself help your
revert brothers and sisters do not miss
out on this golden opportunity and
hasten to earn the reward of a person
doing Jihad absent the fighting as you
sit in the comfort of your own
home brothers and sisters and dear
friends so I came across this video on
Instagram and I was absolutely shocked I
couldn't believe this was coming out
from the official's mouth on in Israel
as you guys know there was a kind of a
ceasefire made which in 4 days between
Hamas and Israel and both sides bear in
mind for some odd reason the
Palestinians who are being kept are
prisoners they're not hostages but from
the other side they're hostages for that
for some odd reason yes they've been
kept hostages as well these and by the
way if you look at the people that have
been released from the Palestinian
prisoners hostages um they are actually
majority women and children very very
bizarre it's women and children now here
is what I heard for myself and this is
basically Israel outright forening their
own citizens who are being released by
Hamas and you can see footages of them
kissing goodbye and waving to Hamas
members and I was like that's a bit
weird and last time they did an
interview with a couple of hostages that
were released they said some good things
about Hamas and the Western media didn't
want to use it and not only that I think
that he got in trouble so let's watch
this video for oursel and here with your
own ears these individuals Benjamin
netanyahu's friend I don't know who he
is for this matter outright threatening
their own citizens if they don't keep
quiet they will be made to be quiet
here's the video declared war the first
thing that the government should have
done was to declare a state of National
Emergency and told all of the hostage
families you will keep your mouths shut
or we will shut them for you you will
not interfere in our management of this
war you will not be used by the
International Community or by our own
leftists who managed the Shalit deal as
a weapon against us and if that means
imprisoning to silence certain members
of the hostage families then so be it
it's we're in a state of War I was dead
set against turning all these posters
out were kidnapped with all these
pictures of so guys can you guys just
imagine that for a second how are they
for some odd reason telling them to be
quiet you know why because they know
that even though like I said before some
of the people like some countries in the
world deem ham to be a terrorist
organization and some don't the point is
that they are being treated more
humanely by this organization that's
some the Western Government government
deem to be terrorist but when it comes
to isra your state a democratic country
the way they have been treating their
prisoners is absolutely crazy if you go
and interview and for some reason the
Western media don't want anything why
don't they go and interview the
Palestinian civilians why don't they go
and see these prisoners these hostages
that were released and see how they were
treated in prison compared to the
Israeli hostages that were kept by Hamas
the point is what that why are you
hiding the bitter reality the truth yes
we said it before and I'll say it again
for us as Muslims we are very clear and
concise with our morality it is
forbidden for anyone from that matter UK
Russia America Hamas anyone to attack or
kill any anyone that's innocent for that
matter the point is that where is
nonbiased Media why don't they cover
these stories because it is clear the
treatment of the Palestinians in Israeli
prisons is abhorent abhorent there's
stuff that have been done to the woman
to the kids one of the man who came out
he was absolutely lost his mind because
he's been locked up for so long so the
point is what if they can do this to
their own people just imagine what they
are capable of doing to the Palestinians
may Allah subh bless you guys share this
video wide far and wide so people can
see the reality on the ground inshallah
and open their eyes to the truth cuz if
the Western media doesn't we will bring
you those news inshallah till next
time